sam farmer the los angeles times on the
program you and peter came with quite
the scoop i mean i i it hit my time on
yesterday i'm like this month is off
the hook crazy absolutely and i want to
talk about that a little bit more with
you once we kind of get through
everything here so when when did it come
on your and peter radar screen that
bruce arians was going to retire from
the nfl when did that happen well we uh
had talked to bruce um
you know this is obviously post um tom
coming back and and uh
we had a talk with bruce over the
weekend
when
i was at the meetings i had arrived at
the meetings
actually i had dinner with bruce on
saturday night uh peter
uh couldn't make the meetings a family
situation wasn't able to make the
meeting so
um
we had known about a few days and highly
unusual to be
behind the scenes i won't say we were
working in tandem but we
um we both understood the timing of this
[Music]
and
you know you might do that with a
colleague at your own place but a guy
from a different media outlet
peter i have known each other for 25
years but
still unusual and uh
you know just very thorough
great integrity we interviewed bruce
together
and uh
it turned out to be a good experience so
okay when i guess then i should have
instead of flipping it i should let's
flip it on to the actual subject of the
uh when did this this time timeline
because the time the timeline of
aryan's decision
is part of a huge conspiracy theory yeah
that as you know was born in february by
brady's initial decision to retire and
the idea was
aryans and he were not getting along so
let's place that aside for the moment
and just get directly into the timeline
as best you can tell of when aryans
decided
and how the announcement came about
yeah so
the days do run together uh i
was talking in the green room to
somebody and uh i thought it was the
weekend right now so my
forgive me if my days run together it
was uh
almost a week probably a week ago maybe
that uh that i knew this was going to be
coming down the pike
and
you know peter and i were careful not to
work too much in tandem we are
competitors but we had a timeout
um
uh an interview with bruce and so that
was i think on
saturday right uh but i'm talking about
aryans decision
well i mean if you if you
listen to bruce
uh
bruce talks about wanting to retire
after last season and really flirting
with the idea of retiring after winning
the super bowl and going out on top and
then jake his son really convinced him
to come back okay and make another run
at it and
so he did and um
i think that bruce was considering
retiring
right after the season uh certainly
after the super bowl watching the super
bowl
and um
you know
he
uh so tom
retired
um
when tom came back bruce to hear bruce
tell it
that set set up todd bowles with a team
um that was a competitor you know the
super bowl competitive team and so bruce
felt like
good about handing it off but i think
bruce was going regardless
so but why then why wait till
march you know what i'm saying like why
if he's gonna go when the window does
close as the interview window closes
he's able to directly hand the team to
todd bowles as opposed to going through
the whole interview process and it locks
in all the assistant coaches
um interesting it's
you know he felt bad about the way he
retired in arizona uh because he wanted
james betcher to be the coach steve
wilkes got the job cardinals went three
and 13 and wilkes lasted one season but
that whole staff got blown out
and so he said by waiting
um
he was able to you know the window
closed i don't know if
if this was his plan or this was just a
happy accident
that
um todd bowles could get the job they
wouldn't have to go through the whole
process the interview process and those
guys would be locked in
those assistants would be locked in but
it is a mystery it's you know people are
gonna
put two and two together they're gonna
speculate about that
and um
you know i don't think tom's ever gonna
come out and say that
that that
this was a quid pro quo or i'll come
back if bruce isn't there and bruce
certainly isn't saying that so i think
uh there's going to be that speculation
well it's the exact opposite i mean you
look at his twitter i mean he's tweeting
out his instagram and all of his yeah
posts brady sends like a big love letter
to bruce arians who i think even
responded on brady's instagram account
with his
you know famed thanks brother with a
with his emojis of his drinking glass
you know
um and so
you know and and aaron's was very
vehement when um i think what it was uh
former player rich orenberger tweeted
out that aryans and and brady were not
at all on the same page that arianes was
you know kind of
sticking his nose in the game plan that
brady and um leftwich had concocted i
mean like that is that is the narrative
so is there any smoke in in that is
there any i guess fire behind that smoke
not from my reporting with with bruce
but again uh i wouldn't anticipate that
he would now
i asked him about that uh you know are
you leaving
uh is this part of tom coming back and
uh and what was your relationship like
with tom and he said listen i've got
friction with every quarterback i've
coached whether it's peyton whether it's
tim couch whether it's andrew luck you
know bruce or ben roethlisberger uh
because i cuss every one of them out and
there's gonna be and you've got two
guys in in
in brady and bruce you got a guy who's
almost 45 a quarterback is almost 45 a
coach who's almost 70 which tells you
they're both going to be set in their
ways yes and know that they have a way
that they like to do things and have
things done
and
uh they're both always going to be on
the bubble of retirement
and
so
again i think this speculation will live
on
forever but i don't think either guy is
going to betray that it's going to be
someone
who was a third party to that
witnessing that and saying that but
i haven't heard that compelling case yet
because the timeline that that you have
laid out and aryans has laid out and the
bucks have laid out and your reporting
with peter king has laid out
does have brady saying farewell right
and does have aryans around the
beginning of march thinking you know
maybe this is going to be it
then brady comes back and then two weeks
later
aaron steps aside and bowles is gone
that does leave enough air in there for
a brady i'm not coming back if aryans is
coming back
yeah and
then
things work in motion where aryans is
like you know what this could be perfect
timing then like i don't
want to have what happened in arizona to
have happened here i can make all the
maneuvers and push the levers to make
sure my guys are taken care of i'm now
going to go in the front office i
leave here my head held high he's not in
a hospital because i know that's part of
his concern is his health concerns right
and it's a win-win all around
like is that a possible
sort of scenario yeah
and you know we don't traffic in this
sort of thing right you know but this is
the stuff that is being trafficked i
don't think the timeline precludes that
uh my reporting uh
at this time has not led me there but
has not barred the possibility of that i
just
um
you know don't have independent
reporting that supports that this was an
arrangement where
you know tom i can certainly see
if you want to follow the breadcrumbs
there you can see that
but um
you know
at least
as far as i know
um i can't say that that that
i can't connect those two uh
with a direct line sure and then because
the timeline does also
um allow for the idea that brady on his
own decides to retire because he just
doesn't know and then he goes through
his six weeks of walkabout or you know
hanging out or what have you yeah and he
decides you know what i really want to
come back and at the same time arians is
going through all of this stuff and he's
like if i wait till after march hey you
know this can actually help out where i
set everybody up
and those two actually come to what
glazer's attention or lights attention
and
voila you've got brady back and aryans
now gone
and
they actually arians and brady genuinely
like each other and that instagram
account is all
flat out like what it intends to be
right right i mean i guess the two
really strange elements of this that the
puzzle pieces that might not
fit is uh you know tom
uh walking away after
you know being in the mvp conversation
and coming so
his age as we've seen that
and picking up velocity when he came to
tampa it really seemed like
uh he got better as opposed to some of
the other quarterbacks at the end of
their careers and payton and
drew brees and losing velocity
and uh and bruce walking away from a
team with with tom brady a chance to win
uh another super bowl and and maybe
cement his uh canton legacy
so
you know that is going to be part of the
big mystery
but it's going to have to be somebody
who else who steps up and
is ready to pass along that information
because i haven't gotten that but i've
certainly heard the
speculation sam farmer the los angeles
times here on the rich eisen show all
right your favorite aryan story you can
tell
is what my favorite aryan story i can
tell is when he was a kid and his mom
worked at the
york a quick kid in york pennsylvania
his mom worked at the york peppermint
patty
factory and would bring home the reject
peppermint patties and in a paper bag in
a grocery bag and bruce one night i was
feeling a little peaked and his mom
brought home one of those
uh bags of peppermint patties and he ate
the whole bag and vomited and now
cannot stand peppermint patties and in
fact
we had uh dinner on saturday night
and bruce uh
was getting a drink and made clear
no mint no mint in the drink please
and i said does that stem all the way
back to the peppermint patty story i got
another bruce story so do you say yes
that he did yes so to this day he does
not he cannot be in the same room as a
peppermint patty
and and they were and he's from york pa
and those were once his staple
a staple to his those
york peppermint patties are so good
they're excellent
yeah
i
can confirm can confirm they are
excellent sources
they are in fact excellent
one or two of them are good another bag
a bag of rejects bag of reject now i
i've been to the jelly belly uh factory
and got in the big bag of belly flops
they call them the the reject jelly
bellies
so i know
what eating to the point of vomiting is
and how that might affect your
tolerance for those things but i i will
tell you one other brucerian's story he
had a bowling class in college
and
it taught him about running a bowling
alley and he was working behind setting
up the pins
uh
and
if it was a uh good-looking girl in the
class or a girl he liked he would reach
through with a broomstick and knock over
the pins
and if there was a guy in the class that
he didn't like he would reach back in
and reset the pins after after the guy's
first roll so he'd set up a
7 10 split he'd manufacture that so um
let me just get this straight so for a
guy didn't like
a guy who doesn't like you know
rolls the ball down the lane it's clear
that like eight pins of knockdown right
yeah so he would then set up the two
remaining pins much further away than
they actually were when he's clearing
when he's clearing the rest he would
just make sure that that uh you know
after the machine he would sneak his
hands in there and make sure that um
he'd set him up with with uh an
unfavorable
setup for a second even if the guy had a
strike maybe he'd set one back up in
i love the guy man yeah he's one of my
favorite people
one of a kind he's one of my favorite
people that i have ever truly met in
this business and lucky to say that his
foundation is great his friend and you
just and i can't wait for the caliendo
video to come out of his retirement
speech or something like that yeah love
the guy i absolutely love the guy sam
farmer here on the rich eisen show uh in
the few minutes i have left with you
here
so
this month has been off
the charts how long have you been
covering the nfl for the los angeles
times or in general just for real in
general uh 28 years okay 20 years what
is hap okay
what is happening
and that's that's i get that a lot from
friends and people tweets whatever like
what
is happening and and and i i know that
that's a general statement but there has
to be a reason
right
why we're seeing so many
movable parts
of what would be previously
unthinkably movable parts
in the nfl this past month well i do
look at the last two years okay look at
the last two super bowl winners and
those are teams that by different
methods got
um an elite quarterback
um
and and
let's particularly look at the what the
rams have done they haven't had a first
round pick since jared goff
um
les snead has dealt those picks and and
the
the notion of
mortgaging your future giving away those
picks finding guys in later rounds but
getting established veterans whether
it's matthew stafford or jaylen ramsey
or any number miller middle of the
season von miller and and uh right they
gave up a lot uh for von miller uh and
and that really set the table for the
broncos to do the
russell wilson move because i think
george payton felt a lot more
comfortable having that fourth round
pick having other picks
um
giving away such a haul
to seattle uh because of that pawn
miller trade so um
so i think
the idea of dealing picks teams are much
more willing to do that and grab
established players but i don't know if
that fully explains it but it is a
copycat league and we see
um
that notion of
uh
by now pay later uh that we really saw
with the niners in 94
uh and the way they were able to parlay
that team early at the first year of the
sauerkraut and karma policy what he was
able to do built that all-star team and
then won the super bowl with that team
um i think people have been chasing that
notion of building an all-star team
and and winning with it and the rams
proved they were able to do that
and i and that
sort of at least set the environment
i think for for some of the things we're
seeing now and then on top of it and
then on top of it too well it's an
excellent theory and then it could be
in convergence
at the same time with a time in the nfl
where players seem to have more leverage
than ever before
a perfect example
perfect example is devonte adams okay
where i think you know if this was five
years ago
yep
and i'm just choosing a number out of
the top of my head but
devonte adams having a franchise tag
and we say in on the show slapped on him
because there are two ways to put a
franchise take you either place it on
somebody or slap it on somebody
depending on how it's received by the
player who's being tagged okay so it's
slapped on him he doesn't want it he
knows it's coming he knows it's going to
be there
and because it's over a year now of
negotiating apparently it goes back to
last summer right where he wants a
contract and then there's an argument
about
you know how to look at deandre
hopkins's contract and real who is the
the highest paid receiver in the nfl on
an annual basis anyway right but that's
what's going on with devante adams five
years ago the answer from the packers
might have been just too bad
your franchise tag
we got aaron rodgers back in the fold
we'll figure it out with you and while
we figure it out with you you're here
uh we don't care that you used to room
with derek carr we don't care that you
want to be
a
uh vegas raider you're here
now though
he's a vegas raider they trade him and
tyree kills another example where a
player might be in a spot where i want
to get paid and the answer would be too
bad
now it's different i think you put those
two things together and
you have march of 2022 off the charts
yeah and i think and it's been building
to this i think the player empowerment
thing has been over the last five years
and we've seen guys uh force their way
out of teams
and um
you know even antonio brown or you know
we've seen guys do what they want to do
and get where they want to get including
deshaun watson getting all that
guaranteed money that's an that's insane
that out of everything that happened
this month
everything that happened this month and
an hour three we're going to run through
everything and good thing we've got a
15-minute segment for it
out of everything happened this month
the the one that might last the longest
in terms of a reverberation is that
deal
that he gets every dollar guaranteed now
is that an aberration or you know is the
russell wilson deal going to be the the
you know the benchmark is that going to
be or is there another deal that's going
to come along
because i know that had a chilling
effect with a lot of gms that wait we're
going to have to start giving 100
guaranteed deals to guys and uh
i'll tell you what i don't want to be
the first gm or or owner to have to deal
with that situation with my um you know
dynamite
face of the franchise and that's why i
have this eric burkhart kyler murray
stationary manifesto sitting on my desk
because
this kid may be the first one up that's
saying every dollar bid mr bidwell
better be guaranteed because i don't
have 22 civil cases and i don't have all
that deposition video that's going to be
leaking out
day in and day out maybe for months and
years to come
you know what i'm saying yeah so i
wouldn't want to be the first one to
deal with that yeah and so you're
basically if you're a gm you're you're
hitching your career to that player and
uh when you're
you know 100 100 of their salary paid
and are guaranteed it's
it's a brave new world
yeah so i think maybe that's what it is
it's just every there's just a few
things that have happened all at once
um
and from from as you say brady saying
let me try something completely
different matthew stafford has the same
idea unless need is like f and all them
picks and then at the same time
players are beginning to
get the nba treatment from nfl owners
and it does feel like it's been
percolating over the years and maybe
this is your this is the year it came to
a head and now we're going to see the
seismic shift uh a seismic shift in the
nfl but um
player player empowerment and i wish i
had more examples that would immediately
spring to mind right now
but uh that's been on the lips of a lot
of people
for a while that that that is changing
the players are getting
um increasing
uh their leverage
and
um it's come to a head this year sam
farmer um greatly appreciate your time
thank you for coming in here i know
you're honored this is awesome this is
we're right across the street
yeah from right across the street
although okay i'm selling them at the
office so thank you for having me
anytime sam you know that and uh
and
um you know you borrowed the best dad
ever placard for me
to have that t-shirt and they've retired
the trophy but
um i think it's neat that you honor me
by bringing that out well you know what
um i think um
you're like the brady you're unretiring
um
you know
you're unretiring it's just a crazy
month it's a crazy month we're all
coming at the title you best not miss as
you know um i don't mean to be so
aggressive certainly since you're kind
enough to be here any time man let's
let's do this again because i mean
by the way
draft month starts tomorrow
in las vegas nevada and then just one
last thing before i send you on your day
gents yes how many times did we come on
the air in january talking about
the super bowl is here
and
one of the two teams that are playing in
the five and a half billion dollar
stadium in los angeles california is
making it and they want it
you sam farmer we're the only one every
single super bowl that i i
witnessed from the start of nfl network
in houston in calendar year 2004 between
jake deloam's panthers
and brady's patriots all the way up
until
probably about five years ago you were
the only one to ask roger goodell a
question about when's football coming
back to los angeles only one what was
that like to you to see that thing
this past year oh
yeah surreal surreal right every uh even
when the stadium was being built i
thought is this really happening is this
uh because that has been the number one
story in my career the number one
focus of my career and and uh
um
you know my capstone question when the
chargers came
rams came chargers games stadium
everything i had to ask that last
question
and that's when i asked roger uh in
houston
it was in houston uh for that patriots
falcons game i asked him uh
when is ellie gonna stop getting teams
what do you say to that oh yeah he
laughed
i did bring up this this trip i did
bring up i said you know the owners
meetings which uh
uh is so inside baseball for us the
owner's meetings there's a rhoda that
it's basically palm beach orlando and
arizona uh so i asked roger this time
actually just off-handedly we were
talking and and i said
uh when is la gonna get an owner's
meeting so that's the new push very good
question by the way i'm all for that
yeah yeah but and there was in one year
it was in uh maui that was when uh tag
labor was retiring that was a basically
retirement gift to tottenham seriously
you laugh here all you want that's
amazing one year it was in maui it was
in hawaii
right and i was there and that was to
say good thanks you know paul bring your
bring your family and we're gonna
we're gonna send you into retirement
with an owner's meeting and that was the
one where i saw tom coughlin in the spa
oh right wow
yeah that was that was where i saw him
like that it was just too far to try i
saw by the way i know we're we're way
over so just before i'd love talking to
you
i saw tom coughlin in his spa i'm
getting ready for a massage he comes in
in a white terry cloth bathrobe and
white terry cloth slippers and we sit
down and it's you know you just hear the
the the water trickling on the bonsai
tree that's there and you hear them you
know the the new age music and i'm just
the coach rich he just sits there and he
goes what time is it i might just look
up at the wall and i'm like it's a
quarter two and he just says my massage
like where's my that [ __ ] it should have
started five minutes ago and he walks up
to the desk and i'm like did i just see
confluent time applied to some poor you
know massage therapist
it was fantastic
i just looked around i'm like i looked
around at all the men's health magazines
and i'm like if somebody else was only
here to actually witness this thing
and i think zen and i think of massages
i think at tom cough it's just
very right you know
at peace with himself
thanks for coming in stanford thanks so
much la times sam far at the la
la times farmer hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here